the only Power that ordinary people
really have in response is taxation
really it's the only thing you can it's
the only Power you have you you have a
vote and you have the power
theoretically to tax through it's the
the only protection that you have if you
look at most of History most of history
is a small incredibly Rich Elite ruling
over a vast majority of incredibly
impoverished people and that is the that
is the present truth in most of the
world and it was true in this country
for most of History we stopped that for
a period of time because we decided no
we're going to make the Rich pay first
level of taxes and we're going to use
that money to allow Ordinary People to
have housing and health care and food
and education we only were able to
achieve that because of high levels of
taxation of the very rich and then in
the 80s we we lost the argument we lost
the argument and in doing that we lost
the only weapon that the poor and
ordinary have ever had to protect
themselves from the rich